It is the best-selling book in history.
No volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted. And its words,
sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious, should always be studied
carefully. It is the Bible, the word of
God. Welcome to Bible Answers Live,
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. To receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, here's your host from Amazing Facts
International, Pastor Doug Batchelor.
Hello, listening friends. Would you like
to hear an amazing fact?
Joshua Slocum lived an astounding life.
Born in Nova Scotia in 1844, he ran away
to sea when he was only 16.
Bright and energetic, Slocum gradually
worked his way from cabin boy and cook
to a respected New England sea captain.
During his illustrious career, he
commanded some of the finest tall ships,
sailing them to exotic ports around the
globe.
Then later in life, Slocum experienced a
series of ill-fated trips, including
mutiny, pirates, and shipwreck.
By 51 years of age, Slocum found himself
back in New England, a penniless
unemployed sea captain.
That's when Joshua Slocum came up with a
unique idea to make use of his extensive
sailing experience.
No one had ever sailed around the world
alone, so he determined to become the
first one.
A sympathetic friend gave him a derelict
37-ft crab boat that he completely
rebuilt, naming it the Spray.
After storing the boat with provisions
and books, on April 24, 1895, he sailed
out of Boston in his tiny sloop.
His route took him to Nova Scotia, to
the Azores, Gibraltar, back across the
Atlantic to South America, through the
treacherous Straits of Magellan, then
thousands of miles across the Pacific to
Samoa, Australia, South Africa, the West
Indies, and finally, in June 1898, he
sailed into Newport, Rhode Island to
complete his circumnavigation of the
globe.
In 3 years, 2 months, and 2 days, he had
sailed 46,000 miles around the world
alone,
with no GPS, no radio, and only the
heavenly lights and a compass to guide
him.
Slocum wrote a best-selling book to
recount his many close calls and
adventures.
Then mysteriously, in 1909, planning an
exploratory voyage up the Amazon, Slocum
set sail from Vineyard Haven,
Massachusetts on November 14,
and was never seen again.
Incredibly, one of the greatest sailors
of the 19th century who sailed a small
boat around the world alone had never
learned to swim.
And did you know the Bible talks about
an army that tried to cross an ocean
without a boat? Stay with us, friends.
We're going to learn more on this
edition of Bible Answers Live.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live,
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions.
Welcome, listening friends, to Bible
Answers Live. We're so glad that you've
tuned in, and if you have a Bible
question, we'd like to encourage you to
give us a call. This is a live
international interactive Bible study,
and here is the phone number to call in
with your questions. 800-463-7297.
800-463-7297.
We do have some lines open, and we are
live, and we'd encourage you to call
now. Very good chance you'll get your
question in for tonight's program. My
name is Doug Batchelor. My name is Jean
Ross. Good evening, friends, and we look
like to also pass it out, welcome those
who joining us on Facebook. And if you
haven't heard, we are live streaming
Bible Answers Live on Pastor Doug's
Facebook page, also on the Amazing Facts
Facebook page. Well, before we get to
our Bible questions, let's start with
prayer. Dear Father, we thank you that
we have this opportunity once again to
open up your word and study the most
important book which reveals truths that
affect not only this life, but really
give us a focus on eternity. So, we want
to ask your blessing upon the program.
Be with those who are listening,
wherever they might be. Lead us, Lord,
into a clearer understanding of the
Bible. We ask this in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen.
Doug, that was a fascinating fact that
you opened the program with. Somebody
you can just imagine they've been quite
a few individuals since then that have
sailed around the world by themselves,
but this is back in the late 1800s,
early 1900s. No GPS, it's amazing. No
radio, no way to call for help in a in a
sailboat. And he sailed all around the
world. It's incredible feat. Yeah, he
didn't even have a sophisticated
chronometer, which they had back then.
He had a $1.50 tin clock with a broken
minute hand. And he was able He was
really a very good navigator. But, you
know, a person can read the book. It's
It's actually been in print for 100
years now. It's been such a standard for
sailors around the world to read about
Slocum's adventure. I'd never read it
until about a week ago, and I thought,
"Well, there is an amazing fact. How did
I miss that one?"
But, what really struck me was at the
end, hearing that, you know, he'd
mysteriously disappeared, and they said
a good chance that he fell overboard,
and he had never learned to swim.
And you think all those adventures
around the world, he should have fallen
over at least once or twice in all the
storms, and somehow he survived all
that. And then, you know, it made me
think about in the Bible,
you have a
a whole army that tried to go across an
ocean without a boat. And then that kind
of Most people are thinking, "What What
does that mean?" Well, friends, you
remember when the Lord parted the Red
Sea for the children of Israel,
and they crossed over,
and that stubborn Pharaoh and his army,
they said, "We can go down into the sea
and try and catch them. If they can do
it, we can do it."
But, they couldn't do it. God worked a
miracle for the Israelites,
but the sea came crashing back in on the
Egyptians,
and God delivered his people. You know,
it tells us that when they when the
Israelites got to the other side of the
Red Sea, they rejoiced for this great
deliverance. And that deliverance is a
story of how God wants to deliver each
one of us,
first and foremost, from sin in this
world and the devil, and ultimately
deliver us when Jesus comes. If you'd
like to know more about that, we have a
free offer we'd be delighted to share
with you. This study guide that we have
talks about an ultimate deliverance.
It's actually what it's called, Ultimate
Deliverance, and it's God's great
deliverance for those who put their
faith in him. It's all about the second
coming, when Jesus comes the second
time. So, we want to encourage you to
get that study guide. It's free. If
you'd like to receive it, the number to
call is 800-835-6747.
That is our resource phone line. If you
have a Bible question, we do have some
phone lines still open. It's a good time
to give us a call, and we'll get your
call on the program tonight. That number
is 800-463-7297.
That'll bring you right here into the
studio. Well, Pastor Doug, I think we're
ready to open up the phone lines. We've
got our first caller here. It's Paul is
listening from Arkansas. Paul, welcome
to the program.
Hey, pastors. How you guys doing? Doing
well.
Awesome. My question is in uh
Daniel 3, when King Nebuchadnezzar
was looking in the furnace,
and uh
saw four
people,
he asked the guards, "Didn't we put
three in? Because I see four, Mhm. and
they're unbound, they're walking around,
and the fourth one looks like the son of
God." And from my understanding,
he was looking at Jesus. Now,
was Jesus in the flesh? Because spirit
incarnated into flesh was through the
womb of the Virgin Mary. However,
Abraham recognized the Lord through an
angel. So, what was King Nebu- King
Nebuchadnezzar, anyway. Nebuchadnezzar.
Yeah, it's a tough one to say.
Yeah, what
What identified him
to or what identified King the king to
see actually Jesus in in human
form? Yeah, good question. He doesn't
use the name Jesus, but he says, you
know, one like the son of God. He, first
of all, keep in mind that
Daniel had spent some time with
Nebuchadnezzar. Now, this is chapter 2.
I'm sorry, this is chapter 3. If you go
back to chapter 2,
Daniel interprets a prophecy for
Nebuchadnezzar, and probably, you know,
tells him something about Jehovah. Cuz
Nebuchadnezzar was ready to worship
Daniel at the end of Daniel's telling
him what his dream was. So, I think
Nebuchadnezzar knew something about the
God of the Israelites, and maybe Daniel
said something about that someday God
would send the Messiah, his son, into
the world. And when Nebuchadnezzar
looked, it was not Jesus incarnate. It
was probably one of the many times that
Christ has appeared
in prior to his incarnation, like when
the Lord appeared to Abraham, or he
appeared to the parents of Samson. And
he he basically And when he appears to
Joshua, Joshua falls down to worship
him. Sometimes he's referred to as the
angel of the Lord,
and meaning the messenger from God, and
Jesus, who brought the great message.
And so, this is one of the It's called a
Christopany, one of of pre-incarnation
um visits of Jesus. He before incarnate
means in flesh. This is prior to his
taking on human flesh.
It was when he appeared in his divinity.
And I think that when Nebuchadnezzar
looked in there, he saw the glory of
this fourth individual surpassed
that of Shadrach, Meshach, and Abednego.
So, does that make sense? Yeah.
Yes, it does. And you know, I I
recall maybe not hearing that he saw
Jesus, but he
that he recognized him as the son of God
you know, which
most likely of course was you know, is
Jesus. So, yeah, and I thought he he was
an angel because and you know, many
times in the Old Testament
the Lord will
appear. Yeah, it's and it's sort of
interchangeable sometimes when when
Christ appeared to some of these
individuals before
his incarnation and he's referred to as
the angel of the Lord. Well, thank you
very much Paul for your question and um
we we appreciate that. Well, good. Our
next caller, we've got Noah listening in
Illinois. Noah, welcome to the program.
Thank you for having me Doug and Jean.
Yeah.
My question is
is there any significance in having
worship like with your pet? Like if you
live alone with pets?
So, you mean like if you're if you're
praying to God, is there anything wrong
with your dog or your cat being there
beside you, you mean?
Like like I like telling like your dog
or cat like Bible stories.
You're telling them about Jesus and his
love. Well, you know, if it's going to
help you, I'm pretty sure they're
probably not comprehending it all, but
if it's going to help you to
um memorize that. I know some preachers
that go to their church the day before
they do a sermon and they preach to an
empty hall to practice and they say it
helps them remember.
So, you know, if but I wouldn't expect
to get a conversion out of your cat,
especially cats. There's more hope for
dogs, but
yeah, you know, I I it doesn't really
say anything in the Bible that you know,
we're to try to be redemptive of our
animals.
You know, God God spoke through a donkey
and the devil spoke through a snake, but
God's going to have creatures in heaven.
But I I don't know that um
you know, I'd be
engaging your pets in worship. Nothing
wrong with them being in the room with
you. Mhm.
All right. Well, thanks for your call
Noah. We've got Becky listening in
Michigan. Becky, welcome to the program.
It's nice to hear from you guys.
Yeah, thank you for calling.
It's been a long time.
Um I got a question. Joshua 24 verses 14
to 15. Chapter 24 verses 15.
Excuse me, I'm a little tongue-tied.
That's all right. Joshua
Joshua 24 verses 15 14 to 15.
All right. Should I go ahead and read
that then? Or Sure. Let me read it just
cuz our a lot of our friends are driving
down the road and they're listening and
give them context. Joshua 24:14 and 15.
Now therefore, fear the Lord, serve him
in sincerity and in truth. Put always
the gods which your fathers served on
the other side of the river in Egypt.
Serve the Lord. Yeah, he said put away
the gods, I'm sorry, that your fathers
served on the other side of the river
meaning in Euphrates.
Serve the Lord. And if it seems evil to
you to serve the Lord, choose for
yourselves this day whom you will serve,
whether the gods your fathers served
that were on the other side of the river
or the gods of the Amorites in whose
land you dwell, but as for me and my
house, we will serve the Lord.
So, your question on that.
The question is um
we know that we have to serve the Holy
Father.
But the question is
we have either um I'm sorry. Um the
question is God gives us
responsibilities to witness to others,
to do what he to do what he would want
us to do. Either we are against our
Heavenly Father or we're for him.
Either we put aside the evil gods
or we learn
Or we serve God. to worship our true
Heavenly Father. Mhm.
So, are you wondering why Joshua asked
that question?
Yeah, I do.
Yeah, some people think that it was
Joshua inviting the Israelites saying,
"Well, which do you want to do?" I think
he's really challenging them to renew
their commitment, reminding them
do not serve the gods that the relatives
of Abraham served. Do not serve the gods
of the Egyptians or the Canaanites and
Amorites in the land that you dwell.
We're going to continue to serve the
Lord. Joshua said, "Don't forget the God
that you know, brought you out of
Egypt." So, it's really an invitation
and a challenge that he's giving the
Israelites there. I don't think he
wanted anyone to say, "Well, let me
think, who shall I serve?"
He was just really reminding them to
have resolve
about serving God. What do you think?
Pastor Ross. Yeah, you know, sometimes
in the Bible a question is asked even
though you might know the answer, but
the question is asked to reinforce a
decision. Mhm. I think Joshua's wanting
the children of Israel here to reinforce
the decision that they're going to serve
the Lord.
Exactly. It's also kind of neat how that
he sets the example for them and says,
"As for me and my house, we've already
made up our mind. We're going to serve
the Lord." So, that's leadership,
especially in the home.
Parents, they need to make a decision.
Make a decision to serve the Lord and
encourage their children to make that
same decision. Yeah, good point.
Thank you very much. Appreciate your
question tonight. All right. We've got
Samuel listening in Wisconsin. Samuel,
welcome to the program.
Thank you brothers for taking my call
and I want to compliment you gentlemen
on your fervor and clarity in declaring
the Bible.
Thank you.
And look and I'm and you guys got me
prepared. I'm looked preparing for
eternity in kindergarten to learn the
ways of the master. Amen.
I got a question on Habakkuk chapter 1
verse 3 and 4 pastors. Could you explain
that to me? All right. Let let's read it
here and this is Habakkuk chapter 1
verse 3 and 4.
Correct. Why why do you show me iniquity
and cause me to see trouble? For
plundering and violence are before me.
There is strife and contention arises.
Therefore, the law is powerless and
justice never goes forth. For the wicked
surround the righteous. Therefore,
perverse judgment proceeds.
You're wondering what what is meant by
that?
Yes, sir. Well, Habakkuk is living
during a time where there was a great
apostasy in Israel.
And they were being um
they were being influenced by their
pagan neighbors.
And so, he's saying, you know, Lord, I'm
beholding the evil
around us and even among your people and
it seems like you know, the law is
powerless that people aren't and the
word law there doesn't just mean 10
Commandments. It meant the word of God.
Seems like they're ignoring the word of
God. There's they're not listening.
There's no justice that's going forth.
The wicked surround the righteous. It's
kind of like Job sometimes said it looks
like the wicked are winning.
And Habakkuk is sort of articulating the
same kind of
um concern, but
you keep reading through the book and
you'll see that he finally exults
in God's righteousness.
But he's you know, kind of bemoaning
what what he's seeing around him.
Reminds of the other verse we read in
the Bible that God is not willing that
any should
um be lost or perish, but he's
long-suffering and that was the case
even with Israel. There was a lot of
corruption.
And God was dealing with them, trying to
reach them. There there was a judgment
that eventually came under the 10 tribes
that with the Assyrians that conquered
them.
The Babylonians came and conquered
Jerusalem and the Jews were taken
captive for 70 years and yet God was was
long-suffering, not willing that any
should perish. And I think Pastor Doug,
we see the same thing even in our world
today where God is long-suffering. We
see a lot of evil in our world
and yet God is wanting to save as many
as possible. Yeah.
And when you read later in the book, you
you can see that he's promising that
you know, even though it looks like evil
is triumphing, that God will win in the
end.
And that great statement that's quoted
so often in the New Testament is in
Habakkuk where he says in
chapter 2 verse 4, "The just shall live
by his faith."
And so, he's saying that the just will
survive and they will succeed.
And that the vision of God's deliverance
will come. Though it looks like it
tarries, don't be discouraged. It will
come.
So, thank you Samuel. I hope that helps
a little bit.
All right. We've got another caller.
We've got Amy listening from Northern
California. Amy, welcome to the program.
Hi.
I'm calling tonight. I had a discussion
with my friend
and we were talking about Revelation 20
where it says the books will be opened.
And I know certain people's writing that
I'm not supposed to mention support this
and say going to great detail that we
will have access to the records.
Um but just wondering if there's any
thing in the Bible that that supports
that more that says the records will be
open to
us to look at for us to look at.
Our Pastor Ross, what's the verse where
it says that don't you know that we will
judge angels? Yeah, that's 1 Corinthians
chapter 6 verse 3 and that's the Apostle
Paul
that talks about the redeemed. It says
the time will come matter of fact, I can
just read it here. It says, "Do you not
know that you shall judge the angels?
How much more things pertaining to this
life?"
So, he's talking to the church. He's
talking to believers and he says the
time's going to come when here the
redeemed will have an opportunity to
review the records. And of course, that
ties in with Revelation chapter 20 where
it says the books were opened. Judgment
took place. Now, the type of judgment
that the redeemed are involved in is not
choosing who's going to be saved and
who's going to be lost. That decision
has already been made. The fact that the
redeemed are in heaven, it means they
are saved.
But, we will be the redeemed will be
reviewing uh the lives and maybe they'll
have questions as to why certain people
are there and why other people are not
there in the kingdom. All of those
questions will be answered during this
time of review when the books are made
available and open. Just like Jesus
said, nothing will be hidden, nothing
that is hidden that will not be
revealed. Nothing spoken in secret that
will not be made known. So, that will be
that time during the thousand years. And
I And then it says I think in Revelation
19 that they'll declare true and
righteous are his judgments. And so,
we're basically uh
exploring the judgments of God so
everyone will trust, you know, his
determinations and they'll declare that.
Thank you. Appreciate that, Amy.
Hope that helps a little.
All right, we've got David listening in
Sacramento. David, welcome to the
program.
David in Sacramento, are you there?
David might have his mute on. David in
Folsom or Sacramento?
All right, we'll come back to to David.
We've got Gail in Canada. Gail, welcome
to the program.
Gail in Canada, you on the air?
Oh, hi.
Hi.
Good to be talking to you and um before
I give my question, just want to thank
you first hand for all the things that
you have um
uh put into the ministry and this had
helped me and my husband a lot.
So, I've been struggling with my
spiritual life and after um watching the
Revelation Now last October, then we
were revived, me and my husband. And my
husband is a Catholic and I am a born
Adventist, but when he watched it we
were both um convicted and he was
baptized uh early uh late in December.
So,
Wonderful. Praise the Lord. Yeah, I just
want to say that for you.
And your So, your question tonight?
My question is um I just um don't
understand this part in Matthew 16 verse
14.
So, it the Pharisees and Sadducees are
asking Jesus what will be the sign and
he said um he will uh he said that
um except for the sign of the prophet
Jonah. I just don't understand that
relationship of
uh Jonah. So, I wanted to know more
about this.
All right. Now, first let me tell you
that uh following my answer tonight, if
you call the resource line there's a
book I've written that we can send you
for free and it's called the sign of
Jonah.
But, if you look in Matthew uh look at
Matthew chapter 12
verse 39
Wow, 39.
And it says, "An evil and adulterous
generation seeks after a sign and no
sign will be given but the prophet
Jonah."
And it also says in the Luke 11
something similar. And he talks about
the the prophet, the sign of Jonah in
Luke 11:29.
So, um here's here's the few things to
think about in that regard is you have
uh Jesus sleeping in a boat during a
storm.
Well, you have Jonah sleeping in a boat
during a storm.
They wake up Jesus and they say,
"Master, we're perishing."
Well, they wake up Jonah and they say,
"Do you not care that we're perishing?"
Uh it tells us that they cast lots at
the cross of Jesus. Well, they cast lots
for Jonah.
Uh Jesus is sacrificed that we might
have peace. Jonah is thrown overboard
that the people might have peace.
Uh Jesus experiences this terrible
suffering for 3 days and 3 nights from
Thursday night when he's betrayed he is
beaten, he's tried, he's whipped, he's
crucified and he suffers the penalty of
suffering and death for sin.
Jonah for 3 days and 3 nights, he
suffers in the belly of the great fish.
Jesus is resurrected. Jonah comes out of
the fish.
Jesus teaches for 3 and 1/2 years
that if the Jews do not repent that in a
generation, which is 40 years, the
temple would be destroyed.
Jonah goes 3 and 1/2 days into Nineveh
and he preaches that in 40 days they
would be destroyed if they did not
repent. So, Jesus said, "As Jonah was a
sign to his generation the Son of Man is
to this generation." So, there's so many
similarities
between the story of Jonah and Jesus
that he was hoping they would recognize
that he was the Messiah.
That That make sense?
Oh, yeah, perfect. Oh, so I know I
understand that um Jesus is like a uh
Jonah is like a type of Jesus. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So, make sure and send for that book,
Gail. It's It's free. We'll send it to
you or anyone that wants it. It's called
the sign of Jonah. The number to call if
you'd like to receive that is
800-835-6747.
That is our resource phone line. And
again, you want to ask for the book.
It's called the sign of Jonah. And we'll
be happy to get that out to whoever
calls and asks.
Uh let's see. We've got uh let's go back
to David in Folsom, uh California.
David, uh welcome to the program.
Are you
talking to me, Doug? Yeah, you're on the
air.
Okay, I'm in Tennessee. That's why I got
confused. That's why I was wondering.
My uh
I was doing a study on the Holy Spirit.
I have so many different answers on what
the Holy Spirit is. Some says the breath
of life is the Holy Spirit. Others say
the spirit was
we were a spirit before we became
a newborn baby. Others say it's
separate, you ask for it, it comes, it's
your guide and protector. Where is the
Holy Spirit? How do we get it? And
secondly, what is it?
All right, great question. Um
first of all, it's crucial that we have
the Holy Spirit. Jesus said, "Unless you
are born of the water and the spirit,
you cannot enter the kingdom of heaven."
We must be born again. It's not the
physical birth. It's a spiritual birth.
And Jesus made it possible for all of us
through his sacrifice to have God the
Spirit indwell us. See, I mean, it's not
like you're being possessed by a
separate person. It's the person of God
actually comes into us, God the the
Spirit. And he then speaks to your
heart, you invite him to lead and to
guide you. He will bring the holy word
to your remembrance.
And um
he he he speaks to you. Now, um
we have and he helps witness through
you. Jesus said, "I'll give you the Holy
Spirit that you might be my witnesses."
Helps us to live the Christian life.
Uh we have a free offer that talks about
how to live a life in the spirit. We'll
be happy to send you a copy of that. I
don't know if you want to add something
to this.
know, just maybe a verse, Pastor. How do
we get the Holy Spirit? Well, uh the
Bible tells us we can ask for the Holy
Spirit. Luke chapter 11 verse 13, Jesus
says, uh "If you've been evil, know how
to give good gifts to your children, how
much more will your heavenly Father give
the Holy Spirit to him who asks?" So,
the first step is ask for the Holy
Spirit and recognize the Holy Spirit is
leading us to to God. Uh the Holy Spirit
is God, is one of the members of the
Godhead. And the Holy Spirit works
within us to lead to conviction and
righteousness and obedience. So, we need
to ask for the Holy Spirit.
Yeah, and so if you you pray, David, you
ask, God says he'll send his spirit into
your life. And we do have a book talking
about the Holy Spirit, the need, the
need for the Holy Spirit. We'll send you
a free copy. The number to call if you'd
like to receive that uh free resource is
800-835-6747.
Just ask for the book All About the Holy
Spirit, The Holy Spirit, The Need. We'll
get it to the mail and and send it right
to you.
All right, friends, don't go anywhere.
We're You can hear the music uh coming
up behind us. We're just taking a brief
break. You can text your friends, tell
them tune in to Bible Answers Live,
something new happening in the studio.
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return shortly.
If you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible Answers Live, you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the Amazing Facts
Prophecy Study Bible. The updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of Amazing Facts 27 study
guides, plus a Bible numbers and symbols
chart and eight pages of colorful maps.
This best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical encyclopedic index, words of
Christ in red, chronology of the Old
Testament, along with Doug Batchelor's
How to Study the Bible feature and much
more. Call us at AF Bookstore to learn
more about it at 1-800-538-7275.
The Amazing Facts Prophecy Study Bible
stands apart from other Bibles, giving
you the same solid answers you hear each
week on Bible Answers Live. Order your
copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275.
What if you could know the future?
What would you do?
What would you change?
To see the future, you must understand
the past. Alexander the Great becomes
king when he's only 18, but he's a
military prodigy. A 150 years in
advance, Cyrus had been named.
Rome was violent, they were ruthless,
they were determined.
The gospel writers see his death as a
fulfillment of salvation.
This intriguing documentary, hosted by
Pastor Doug Batchelor, explores the most
striking Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history, Kingdoms in Time. Get your copy
today. Available now on DVD, Blu-ray, or
USB. For more information, visit
kingdomsin time.com.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live,
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you. So, what are you waiting for?
Get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today.
If you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life, call us
now at 800 God says. That's 800
463-7297.
Now, let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible Answers Live.
Welcome back, listening friends, to
Bible Answers Live. You heard the
number. If you have a Bible question,
give us a call. 800-835-6747
brings you into the studio.
And uh you know, you may want to also go
look at the Facebook page because you'll
see that uh if you've ever tuned in and
watched the video of Bible Answers Live,
things are radically different right
now. We finally got moved into the new
Amazing Facts studios, and we're still
adjusting the furniture a little bit.
This is your second week here, my first
week here.
And uh so, it's really nice to see a a
nice, clear, crisp picture. And the plan
is that uh in a few weeks, we're
actually going to take Bible Answers
Live onto television. To start with,
it'll be on AFTV live. We'll probably do
reruns during the week. And there's some
other networks that have showed some
interest. So, you'll not only be able to
hear it, you'll be able to see it. And
we hope that uh
you If you want to take a peek, just go
to the Amazing Facts Facebook page or
the Doug Batchelor Facebook page, and
we're streaming a sample of that right
now. I am Doug Batchelor. My name is
Jean Ross, and we're going to go to the
phone lines. Our next caller is Rob, and
he's listening in England. Rob, welcome
to the program.
Oh, yeah. Hi there. Um well, greetings
from the UK. It's uh quite late here, to
be honest, but um
I'm glad I've got through. Um I didn't
think I was going to get through, but
I'm I'm very happy I have, so. Thanks
for waiting up. Yeah, appreciate that.
And your question tonight?
Yeah, so my question is regarding a
divorce, basically. So, I've been with
someone for 3 and 1/2 years.
And I'm I've only, you know, been 18
months into the faith, so I'm I'm not
saying I know everything, but about 11
months ago, I discovered um about, you
know, remarrying someone who's been
divorced. So, I just kind of wanted some
clarification on that because when my uh
partner, who I'm not married to her, by
the way, yet, got divorced, she wasn't
born again. You know, she wasn't aware
of that scripture when she divorced her
her ex-husband. Um and we're looking to
get married now, but unfortunately, also
as I said, I found the scripture that
says you can only marry you know,
remarry someone if they've the you know,
the hus- her husband divorced for if she
divorced husband for biblical reasons.
So, yeah, I just wanted to get some
clarification around that. If the person
if she divorced her ex-husband, but they
she wasn't aware of that scripture, then
it would it still be, you know, commit-
would you still be committing an
adultery? So, that's kind of what I
wanted clarification around this.
great question. Now, the the verse where
Jesus talks about uh divorce and
remarriage, um he doesn't apply that to
a person who is like grown up a pagan.
Uh cuz the reason we know that is you
look at the story in John chapter 4,
where Jesus has this encounter with the
woman at the well, who has been married
five times, and she's living with
someone she's not married to, and yet
Jesus reveals to her that he's the
Messiah,
which means he certainly accepted her,
and she would be saved. I don't know if
she went home and married that guy or
kicked him out, or what happened there.
Um but you know, I think when you come
to the Lord, the Lord kind of gives you
uh a new beginning. You cannot
unscramble scrambled eggs. And so, you
know, if you're out in the world and
you're you're pagan, and there's people
that may get divorced and remarried, and
and then finally, they have a
conversion, and they want to live a
Christian life. Well, does that mean
they've got to go hunt down their former
spouse and remarry them? Of course, they
could be married to someone else at that
point. I think the Lord gives us a fresh
start. You're born again. And uh now,
once you're a Christian, and you know
better, that's a little different. Uh
it's it's not a little different, it's a
lot different cuz sin is knowing to do
good and not doing it.
So, I don't know, Pastor Ross, you have
anything to add?
Yeah, no, absolutely. God is a god of
new beginnings, and I think if somebody
comes to an understanding of the truth,
and you commit your life to Christ, you
know, it is important, and we would
encourage you. We know you've showed an
interest in spiritual things, you've
gotten converted, but it would be good
that before you get married, that um
your fiance also take time to read and
study and see what the Bible says. Uh
the Bible does give a lot of counsel
that when one gets married, you want to
make sure that you share the same faith,
that you're united in your belief.
Otherwise, that can cause all kinds of
other problems in the marriage, so uh
hopefully, she's willing to to consider
that as well. And then I think, you
know, you ask God's blessing, you get
married, ask God's blessing upon your
relationship, and and move forward in
faith.
Yeah, that's what I do. I do We do both
pray every day to um you know, ask God
to for for directions. I just have one
more quick question. I hope that's okay
cuz it's quite late here, so. Sure. Um
it's regarding the Sabbath day,
basically. I just wanted to know again,
I am quite new to the faith. I'm only 18
in- 18 months into being a Christian, so
I certainly don't claim to know
everything. I'm still learning. It's
progression every day.
Um so, on the Sabbath day, um
I just wondered, you know, I'm I hope
this isn't a silly question because I
said I am new, so please excuse it if it
is a silly question.
worry about it. But um
you know, you
I I I know that's a day when, you know,
your your thoughts are to be of God,
like it says, remember to keep the
Sabbath day holy. Like you said before,
Doug, it's the only one that does begin
with remember. But in terms of like
cooking and stuff like that, are we
allowed to cook on the Sabbath day? I
mean, because I feel I do feel guilty
for going in the kitchen sometimes and
spending half an hour, 45 minutes in
there.
Um
if someone calls me, a friend, and we
end up going off subject, I mean, I try
to keep it about God, but they might
tell me about, you know, their day
yesterday. And I I just feel guilty
constantly if I All right, you got two
questions there.
about God. Yeah, good good questions.
All right, let's take it one at a time.
First of all, when it comes to cooking,
there's actually scriptures that say
that as far as possible, we ought to
bake what we're going to bake, and maybe
Pastor Ross will find a bake what you're
going to bake, and I think it uses the
word seethe or boil what you're going to
boil. In other words, do as much cooking
as you can. The principle is that you
want to be able to enjoy the day and
rest. Uh you know, Karen and I might
heat something up, or you you might
microwave something. There's nothing
wrong with that. Or if you've got a
salad, it may be a lot fresher if you,
you know, uh put certain things in it on
the Sabbath day.
Um you have that verse? Yeah, the verse
you're referring to Exodus chapter 16
verse 23. And this is the background of
the story that we're getting manna that
God is giving them. And God said on on
Friday, on the sixth day, gather what
you need for for the both the Friday and
the Sabbath, and then prepare it on
Friday so that there's less cooking
taking place on the Sabbath. Yeah.
But as Pastor Doug mentioned to to add
to that, it's by no means a sin to to go
into the kitchen and you know, rinse off
your salad and put in your bowl and get
ready to eat. I think the the Bible's
speaking about major cooking. You don't
want to bake your pies on Sabbath. Get
that done on on Friday.
Yeah, and then uh you asked another
question about, you know, you have
friends that aren't believers, and they
call, and they want to discuss just the
worldly chit-chat, and it can sometimes
be a challenge. Um you know, I I think
it takes um it takes a while to kind of
let your friends know that this is your
Sabbath day. And you know, you can share
with them your faith. It's certainly a
great day to give Bible studies. It's
always a challenge if you're going to
visit family,
uh and they're not believers, and uh you
know, they want to talk about the latest
football game or whatever's going on.
That's probably going on right now.
A- A- So, uh
you know, and it you just need to be
sensitive to love people, and at the
same time, try and steer your thoughts
towards spiritual things. Now, we do
have a book, a free book. I don't know
if we can send it to England. You might
be able to read it for free online.
And it's dealing with some tips on how
to keep the Sabbath day holy. Yes, and
if you'd like to read that, just take a
look at the Amazing Facts website, just
amazingfacts.org.
You also asked some questions about the
Sabbath, and we just want to let folks
know about a website that Amazing Facts
has. It's called Sabbath Truth, just
sabbathtruth, filled with all kinds of
scripture and some great lessons. I
think it'll be a blessing to anyone who
looks that up. Well, thanks for your
call, Rob. We're glad you were able to
get through. We've got Rachel listening
in Florida. Rachel, welcome to the
program.
Hi, how are you? Good. How are you
doing?
I'm good. So, my question is this. Since
we can't eat any unclean meat or touch
it when it's dead, can we use leather or
silk or boar hair bristles and things
like that?
Okay. Um in a in a word, yes. And the
reason I know that is cuz in the Bible,
the Bible tells us that uh these Bible
heroes, they would not eat unclean
animals,
but they might wear them. John the
Baptist, it says he wore camel hair.
And uh the uh camel's not clean to eat
uh in the Bible, of course, they they
made a lot of things out of leather. And
I think some translations say that the
covering of the sanctuary was badger
skin or seal skin.
That it's the Hebrew word is not clear,
both of which would be, you know, an
unclean animal for food. So, there's not
a prohibition in the Bible to using uh
some part of uh an animal as a tool or
for clothing. It was really you
shouldn't be ingesting an unclean animal
cuz your body's a temple of the Holy
Spirit and and of course there's all
kinds of um
health problems with the animals that
God declares unclean. And of course
donkeys were used quite a bit in in
Bible times. You had Mary that rode on
the back of a donkey to Bethlehem,
Joseph.
But it was a live donkey.
It was a living donkey. Still an unclean
animal.
Yeah. You don't want to eat it. Jesus
entered Jerusalem riding on the back of
a donkey. So, you have nothing wrong in
having dogs and cats, both of which are
unclean. But the Bible's speaking
against eating those animals.
Yeah, very good. All right, thanks for
your call, Rachel. We've got Michael in
Florida. Michael, welcome to the
program.
Hello, how you doing, pastors? Can you
guys hear me? We do, loud and clear. All
right.
Great. Um so, yeah, my question is um
actually something I remember I I called
in probably a few months ago and I said
this part just as a preface to another
question, but now I'm going to ask about
this thing specifically.
And that is um
I you know, I've I've been raised um
I've been raised in the church and the
thing is um a few years ago I came to
this place while I was just like sort of
introspecting
where I don't know how much I can say
I've you know, how much of my faith is
based upon true personal conviction as
opposed to me just uh following what I
was taught to believe in. And this sort
of thing has um sort of thought process
really has
caused me to become I guess more
skeptical about my faith in in terms of
like, you know, different things I've
heard cuz I'm pretty sure that like a
the question on
skepticism or discussion on skepticism
can really proliferate into a myriad of
topics like, you know, uh
uh
like I as far as I was raised in terms
of biblical teaching, the earth is 6,000
years old, God created everything. And
then uh but then there's like the
skepticism raised by say for instance
like evolution or or you know,
scientific evidences that I seem to run
against um biblical teaching and and
well, like I said, it's not just you
know, that's just just in terms of like,
you know, that uh specific uh facet, but
a a myriad of other things um and I just
wanted to know, is there like a a
biblical
uh
a course of action in terms of
addressing skepticism and and
Yeah. Yeah. I I think Well, first of
all, um I think that when you ask
questions, you want your faith to be
based upon a personal conviction and not
solely upon what maybe your parents or
the pastor said. Uh you need to be able
to um evaluate your faith and be able to
defend it. Peter, you know, said, "Be
ready to give an answer." I grew up, you
know, not believing in God. I was
atheist or agnostic and believed in
evolution and uh
you know, just very pagan in my
approach. And so, when I was exposed to
Christianity, I had a lot of I was from
New York anyway, and so I had heard a
lot of questions, a lot of skepticism. I
had all the questions about evolution. I
wanted to be satisfied that it wasn't
just because the Bible said so, but I
thought that the evidence of logic and
science
and for me, it, you know, now it it
seems like in the last 20 years with the
explosion of knowledge
in the um
you know, microbiology
and DNA that uh it is so precise
that, you know, we would never believe
if you saw a computer program that there
wasn't a computer programmer.
Um everybody knows if you're running a
computer program, it took great genius
to develop that program.
Well, human
life, the the eye, the brain, the world
is so incredibly complex that it's it's
statistically very far-fetched to think
these things came together without
intelligence.
And I know you might say, "Well, then
all right, so I believe that God made
things, but maybe he used evolution to
make them."
Well, if God says he did it very
quickly,
then whatever evidence you see in the
world, you know, God can accelerate that
and and I think that um men are guessing
what happened thousands or millions of
years ago and all they can do is guess
based on what they see now.
So,
it's nothing wrong with asking
questions. Faith comes by hearing and
hearing by the word of God. Spend more
time
talking to the Lord, trusting what his
word says. When you study prophecy
and you see how dependable the Bible is,
it increases your faith in the other
things the Bible says. Well, you know,
one of the thing, Pastor Deck, for for
all of the um scientists that might be
um
spouting off uh evolution as being a
trustworthy theory, there are just as
intelligent scientists who are exposed
to the very same material, who are
staunch creationists, who are believing
based on what they see
in nature, based upon their studies,
that there is a God that created these
things. So, typically in the media we
hear one side of the story, but there
are God-fearing, believing scientists
who have hold the same education, the
same skills, who see things differently.
Yeah, they don't get very much airtime.
They're kind of uh they've been kind of
excluded from the airwaves.
Mhm. But yeah, that's true. There are a
lot of very brilliant scientists and
engineers and biologists and
and um
they believe in the biblical creation is
actually scientific. You know, there's a
book we have. We haven't given it out
very often, but it's a great little
book. It's called How Evolution Flunked
the Science Test. And we'll make that
available to anyone who would like to
receive it. You can just call and ask.
The number is 800-835-6747.
And again, you can ask for the book How
Evolution Flunked the Science Test. And
it gets into some of the details here of
of where
what we see in nature and what science
is revealing actually supports the
teachings found in the Bible. And I
think you'll be encouraged by looking at
that.
All right. Well, thank you for your
call, Michael. We've got Lisa listening
in New Jersey. Lisa, welcome to the
program.
How you doing? How you feeling?
Doing good.
Thanks for calling.
My question was when the Bible does it
say when Jesus died?
All right. Luke 23:46.
I can read it to you here. It says, "And
when Jesus had cried out with a loud
voice, he said, 'Father, into your hands
I commit my spirit.' And having said
this, he breathed his last."
So, there is a passage in the Bible. Is
that what you're asking?
No, I was asking when did he die? Oh,
when? The time?
like what time of day or what time of
year?
Like a both, the day and the year.
Yeah, uh
near as we can tell, Jesus died 31 AD
and it tells us it was during the
Passover, which would be in the spring.
So, Christ was crucified, you know,
depending on what the moon was doing cuz
the Jews were on a lunar calendar. So,
based on our calendar, it would have
been sometime between uh the end of
March, beginning of April
that he died uh during the Passover.
Bible tells us he died on the
preparation day. We know the preparation
day would be a Friday. And he rose the
first day of the week. We know that
would have been Sunday morning early.
So, um And he died on the cross at 3:00
in the afternoon. That's right. That's
what hour it was. Yep. So, quite a bit
of information is given there. Yeah.
All right. Well, hopefully that helps uh
Lisa to give you some more information
on that. Um we've got Preston in Texas.
Preston, welcome to the program.
Hi.
Hi, thanks for calling.
Yeah, thank you. Um my question is
um
uh
is it a sin to buy food on the Sabbath
like to uh buy food at Taco Bell or
something?
Oh, you mean like going out to a
restaurant? Well, uh
I tell you I believe first of all, the
Bible does tell us in Nehemiah and
Pastor Ross might have to tell me the
verse again. When uh the pagans were
coming to Jerusalem to uh buy and sell
their products, fish and other things,
he sent them away. He said, "It's the
Sabbath day. Don't come by the gates."
He warned them two or three times.
Finally he said, "Look, if you come
back, I'll arrest you." He they weren't
to be doing their buying and their
selling. I don't know if you have that,
Pastor Ross. Yeah, Jeremiah 17 talks
about not buying on the selling buying
on selling on the Sabbath. Uh but hallow
the Sabbath day, Jeremiah 17:22. And
then there's also one in Nehemiah where
Yeah, that he he says that as well. Um
but now you're asking like, you know,
what about going out to dinner? And the
the approach that I take and I think
Pastor Ross feels the same way is
if uh if we think it's a good idea for
us to prepare and to be able to rest on
the Sabbath day, then why do we want to
hire someone else to do our cooking for
us?
And um
basically you're engaging them directly
to work for you on the Sabbath day. And
so, I think, you know, um we should
prepare in advance. That's why Friday,
the sixth day of the week, is called the
preparation day. As you get your food
prepared, you make your plans. And the
other thing is when you go to usually
the typical public eating place, it's uh
not always a very uh spiritual
environment as well.
Now, um the ideal is to prepare and
that's why the Bible talks about uh you
know, Friday being the preparation day.
You you get ready for the Sabbath.
Um but there are situations where
somebody might be sick and they need to
buy some medicine. Uh that's permissible
on the Sabbath if if you can relieve
suffering. Uh somebody might have a need
for, you know, a diabetic or something
and they might need some food almost
like medicine at some point you don't
have anything.
You know
those type of exceptions but I I think
we want to prepare beforehand. Yeah, if
you can plan sometimes they'll be
extenuating circumstances. I remember
once our family was traveling overseas
and it was like a two-day flight home
and halfway home
uh you we got delayed and it turned out
that you know we ended up in a strange
city on the Sabbath day with no food
there's nothing we could down about it
it was a weather related thing.
And we we had to go buy some food
we have to get young children.
So you know you'll sometimes run into a
a rare situation like that and and God
is reasonable but otherwise I think we
ought to plan.
Okay, well thank you for your call
Preston. We've got another caller from
Sacramento. We've got um
uh let's see Manashi
uh from Sacramento. Welcome to the
program.
Manashi Sacramento I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing your name correctly.
Manash
Sacramento you have your mute on?
All right we'll come back to that person
we got Yeah there you are. Welcome.
me now? Okay.
Thank you.
And your question?
Yes my question is about Romans 14 and
what Paul writes there
um
specifically uh verse 5
and 14 they seem to be saying that um we
can worship on any day and eat anything
is
to me.
Um so I I know that God is is very
particular about what we eat and the day
that we worship on. So can you please
explain what he was saying in Romans 14?
Yes we'll do our best. Uh let me read
this for everyone Romans chapter 14
verse 5. Uh first let me give you the uh
the background.
The Jewish Christians the Jews that
accepted Jesus were telling the new
Gentile converts in Rome
that you cannot eat
um the things that are sold in the Roman
marketplace because the Romans whenever
they ate uh an animal whenever they
butchered a sheep or a goat or chicken
they offered it to a pagan God.
And so the uh Jewish Christians were
saying you can't eat that it's been
offered to idols.
And so you should only eat vegetables
cuz any meat that you're going to eat in
Rome has been offered to a pagan deity.
And I think there's a verse in
Corinthians where Paul says eat what's
sold in the shambles for asking no
questions for conscience's sake.
And then also the Jewish Christians were
telling the Gentile Christians you need
to keep all the annual Sabbath days. You
need to keep the Passover Feast of
Trumpets Feast of Tabernacles and Paul
is saying uh no those were all nailed to
the cross.
One man this is Romans 14:5 one person
esteems one day above another another
one esteems every day alike let each one
be fully convinced in his own mind. Now
right away we know Paul is not saying
some of you may want to go to church on
the Sabbath some may not just whatever
you feel like. I've never heard a pastor
in a Sunday church tell his people that.
Mhm. And they
they say this is a day you're supposed
to be here so no one ever uses it that
way until they hear the Sabbath truth.
And then he goes on and he said um
he who observes the day observes it to
the Lord and he who does not observe the
day to the Lord he does not observe it.
He who eats eats to the Lord for he
gives God thanks and he who does not eat
to the Lord he does not eat and he gives
God thanks.
So he's talking about two specific
problems that were being brought in and
had nothing to do with well if you feel
like keeping one of the 10 Commandments
that's good if you don't whatever you
feel like.
And if you feel like being careful what
you eat
fine if not just say a prayer and eat
anything.
That this is not what Paul is saying
here.
Yeah and if you'd like to get some extra
verses on what Paul feels about the 10
Commandments you just need to read a
little further in Romans where Paul says
the the law is holy just and good. Uh
matter of fact he tells us to keep the
Commandments to obey God so he's not
talking about the seventh-day Sabbath
here by any means. And again as you
mentioned the context helps us
understand what he's talking about. Mhm.
Well thanks for your call we've got uh
let's see Freddy is listening in New
York. Freddy welcome to the program.
Hi pastor good good night good night.
Evening. In the
in the book of Revelation
it talks about the seven churches.
But there are really only seven
churches?
No there probably uh hundreds of
churches by the time John wrote the book
of Revelation there were little plants
and home churches all across
everywhere from Egypt uh up until Rome.
But the reason that the seven churches
are mentioned seven of course in the
Bible is a um a very significant number.
Seven represents it's like a perfect
cycle.
And when John writes his seven messages
to the seven churches of Asia it's not
all the churches it's seven churches and
it's almost like he's going in a mail
route it forms a circle he does them in
order in on a map you can look
and he writes to these seven churches
and those seven messages to the seven
churches represent a cycle of
experience.
For one thing it's a panorama of the
history of the church
from the first coming of Jesus to the
second coming.
It also can represent a cycle a person
goes through if they're not careful in
their faith. I've seen some people start
with Ephesus
enthusiasm and they end up Laodicea.
And then there are different church
families that not only individually a
church family can go through any one of
those conditions. I've met churches that
are Philadelphia full of brotherly love
and then I've met churches that are
Thyatira full of idols. Mhm. So
um there's just so much here Pastor Ross
he has kind of a special interest in it.
Yeah and as you said Revelation has a
series of sevens you got the seven
churches you got the seven seals
you got the seven trumpets later on in
Revelation you find the seven plagues
but the seven churches the seven seals
and the seven trumpets really parallel
that same time period uh basically the
Christian era from the first century
after Christ all the way through to the
second coming and even beyond and so it
emphasizes different aspects of the
experience of the last 2,000 years of
its history.
So hopefully that helps a little bit.
Hey thank you very much for your
question and you know we do have an
advanced Bible study series that talks
about Revelation and uh if they go to
the Amazing Facts website and they can
sign up you can even just go to Bible
University and at Bible University
you'll see our Bible study series there.
We've got two or three different
versions of that. Hey thank you for
joining us friends for Bible Answers
Live and uh we hope that you can tune in
next week. Don't forget that this is a
completely faith-based program. If
you're hearing us on a station now it's
because people just like you are doing
something to keep us on the air and by
God's grace we've been doing this now
for about 25 years. All by faith. Just
go to amazingfacts.org
amazingfacts.org
and you can click donate and we will
appreciate it God will bless you. Take
care we look forward to studying his
word together again next week.
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts International a faith-based
ministry located in Granite Bay
California.
Find out what the critics are raving
about. Top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation.
With powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95-minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before. Revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today.
Visit iTunes or afbookstore.com.
Journey back through time to the center
of the universe.
Discover how a perfect angel transformed
into Satan the archvillain.
The birth of evil
a rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth.
Behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans.
Witness the temptation in Eden.
Discover God's amazing plan to save his
children.
This is a story that involves every life
on earth.
Every life.
The Cosmic Conflict if God is good if
God is all powerful if God is love then
what went wrong?
For life-changing Christian resources
visit afbookstore.com.
If you'd like to enhance your study of
God's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free Bible study
course. And make sure to check out our
online bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's word. To take
advantage of the offers you've heard on
this broadcast call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org.
Did you enjoy this program? Make sure to
tell your family and friends. Tune in
next time for more Bible Answers Live
honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions.